I don't really know how to introduce
this next story to you
North Korea is known for producing
propaganda videos and the hallmarks of
these videos are total delusions of
grandeur with regard to Kim jong-un
portraying him as almost like a god-like
unquestionable hero narcissism
narratives that make no sense a really
ostentatious tone and we learned that
right before Donald Trump and Kim
jong-un walked into the room for the
Singapore summit one of these propaganda
type videos was played and in the room
initially people believed that this was
a North Korean video that the music and
the content everything seemed like North
Korean propaganda portraying Pyongyang
is some kind of amazing cosmopolitan
paradise it was later learned that this
was a White House produced video the
White House produced and played a video
that was indistinguishable from North
Korean propaganda right before the
summit take a look at some of it seven
billion people inhabit planet Earth of
those alive today only a small number
will leave a lasting impact and only the
very few will make decisions or take
actions that renew their homeland and
change the course of history history may
appear to repeat itself for generations
cycles that never seem to end there have
been times of relative peace and times
of great tension while this cycle
repeats the light of prosperity and
innovation has burned bright for most of
the world and history is always evolving
and there comes a time when only a few
are called upon to make the difference
but the question is what difference will
the few make the past doesn't have to be
the future out of the darkness can come
the light and the light of hope can burn
bright what if
of people that share a common and rich
heritage can find a common future their
story is well known but what will be
their sequel yeah so it's an
embarrassment beyond words that the
white house would produce such a video
period but it is especially embarrassing
that it portrays North Korea in this way
right it's portraying North Korea as
this just idyllic place kids are
skipping through Pyongyang Kim jong-un
is waving to crowds of adoring people it
is White House produced propaganda in
the style of North Korea and then
putting all doubt to rest last night
Trump himself actually shared it on
Twitter saying here is the video a story
of opportunity that I shared with Kim
jong-un at the Singapore summit there is
one possible defense of this which I've
already heard from trumpets and that
defense is David Trump knows that this
is propaganda the White House knows that
this is propaganda this is just to
butter up Kim jong-un to get him to make
commitments that we want him to make if
that's the case it failed because Kim
jong-un committed to nothing and made
only the same sort of vague statements
of support for unenforceable future
denuclearization can you believe that
this is now what the White House is
producing I mean P it was interpreted as
North Korean propaganda and it was an
official White House video yeah I mean
what what else could they possibly be
doing though in that White House I guess
there's nothing else to fill that time
that they have day to day
I guess maybe somebody there actually
thought like this this makes sense right
let's couch this entire thing as an
historic event and they are certainly
saying that that it was in an
ubiquitously positive way I agree that
this is historic in the sense that most
presidents have understood the risks of
meeting with North Korean leaders
without preconditions without having
them previously make sort of real
commitments to change I hope I'm wrong
that's my sort of final point on this
North Korea thing I hope that I'm wrong
and that we really do see the reforms
from North Korea that so many in the
West and and in South Korea and in Japan
and even in China have been hoping for
for decades at this point I've explained
clearly why
I remain skeptical but please the White
House should not be involved in the
production of North Korean style
propaganda discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash re d
di t luke vargas joins me from singapore
after the break